i i kind of felt like i was prepared for
a show like i was i don't usually get
this fancy on the show pretty rocking
thank you i know i like it i feel like
you would wear it especially this belt
yes i like the belt how are you doing
i'm really excited to be here i'm very
nervous that you're here
no literally like you and like meryl are
my that's my oh my god yeah so they're
like my favorite stuff look at these
outfits i know we're very 80s so great
okay so congrats on the lifetime
achievement award that was that was this
month that's amazing
that's so cool
is getting that kind of stuff does it is
it weird for you get up there and like i
mean i can't even imagine being you
getting up there winning that kind of
award thinking of all the amazing things
that you've been a part of that you've
done that you've helped be amazing and
and because we're going out on tour and
i'm not i'm not hanging up my spurs yet
i know i really like to get it now we're
very excited we've made the staples i
know
i know my hero she we literally were
texting about it last night and i was
like what i was gonna ask you who are
some of like your like heroes musically
well mavis absolutely those staples
singers from the time that they were
backing up dr martin luther king yeah
and um you know speaking of 80s how
about what classic of all time aretha
franklin oh my god i love him rachael
yeah but whitney for 80s man yeah
you know i mean there's just so many and
for roots artists like me and delbert
mcclinton and little feet and people
like that it was a rough decade on that
because they weren't playing our kind of
music on the radio until the end of the
decade and it was just by the time nick
of time won people went wow that's just
all kinds of music mixed into one so
that and that's why you're one of my
favorites like i and that's uh linda
ronstadt's one of my favorite i just
love any artist that's like
doesn't pigeonhole themselves because
that's my favorite thing about music is
i love country music and i love pop i
love so i grew up on nirvana i grew up
on everything i know i love it too
that's one of the reasons i love you
because you're really eclectic
that's i get it from you um but i i love
that one but i love annie oh my god me
too me too i'm just talking with bonnie
ray don't worry about it america we're
back with mommy right in a celebration
of the 1980s because it's my birthday
week um so you i heard that you briefly
worked with prince in the 80s is that
correct i did i did prince called me up
and said hey you know you weren't
treated right come on over to paisley
park let's make a record together i love
that
and um
i said if we can meet in the middle you
know i don't necessarily want to do a
whole prince thing and you don't want to
do a bounty rate thing so
i had a ski accident and fell on my
thumb and had to be in a cast for two
months so i had to postpone working with
him which is why i don't work out and
then i was like i was like 35 40 pounds
heavier and i went you know if i do a
video with this guy if we if the song
works and it's really sexy
i gotta do something i said i gotta i
gotta work on this so i used the cast as
an excuse to lose weight and i just i
said you know i better quit drinking too
because it gets you know in your 30s you
put on pounds a lot easier i've noticed
so
so i ended up hanging out with some
friends of mine that were sober and i
went you know what this feels really
good so i lost 20 pounds before i worked
with prince i loved it that's what did
it and that's kind of what did it
because i was so terrified of being in a
video with him and not not like looking
and saying all that sexy stuff to me and
going i don't think this people are
going to believe that
i have to ask this because i didn't know
that you had like a bagpipe phase oh my
god which family is scott our family is
scottish roots okay but a lot of people
have scottish roots that don't play the
bagpipe
but i really love the sound of bagpipes
it's beautiful and i i i got it on a you
know consignment you know yeah thrift so
whatever you call that this sheet when
you get used stuff you know the
newspaper and you know remember those
and i did for sale and i bought them
yeah and it and i asked i in my college
paper i advertised in the one ads for
anybody that knew how to blow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then it said like this bagpipes
underneath that was my ass oh my god i
was like what kind of results happened
afterwards and then i got i said you
know how to break that
freshman wants to learn but freshman
wants to learn and my and my um
my housemates at my dorm they wouldn't
let me learn because it just sounds like
someone's being strangled what's so loud
yeah oh it's terrible yeah really bad
but it is beautiful and i was like
passing out from i didn't have the air
to blow through to sustain yeah yeah it
seems hard i like it too hard i know it
was too hard for me i'm glad i stuck
with the guitar you know i think we all
are yeah
i think that was a solid decision so
wait this is is this 21 this album is it
number 21 number 21 that's amazing
so what out of all the albums what do
you feel like makes this one different
well i wanted to write i was really
inspired by especially because we lost
john prine this last year to coven and i
i love his story songs like angel from
montgomery and donald lydia and you know
jackson brown's early records i love
that finger simplicity of a
finger-picking song telling a story so
this this record has a couple of mine on
there that are a third person kind of
story about taking that taking on the
character of somebody else besides me
yeah because i really which is fun
because you can get into all my personal
life already and i said yeah
in the first 20 yeah exactly so that's
different from me i went back to my
roots kind of just played folk guitar
and sang these story songs and then i
wrote a rocker that's uh to my guitar
player's uh track that was just too good
to give up i had to play you know dual
guitar with him and i wrote a song for
all the people we lost even for the ones
who didn't make it yeah so wait what's
the story behind the title track just
like that just like that i was watching
the evening news and sometimes they have
a human interest story at the end
and they said oh we're going to follow
this woman to the house of the man who
received her son's donated heart oh and
they followed her into the house and he
said just sit down he said would you
like to put your head on my chest and
listen to your son's heart and i i just
i lost it i just lost and i was so
moved by the story that i ended up
writing a character and writing a song
about what it would be like for both
those people
to experience that oh my god what a line
yeah oh my god that's
that's so incredibly sad but beautiful
at this time that's how i feel about it
i mean we need to we need stories that
really open your heart in these
difficult times yeah um i can't let you
leave this room without talk i know i've
mentioned it to you before but you're i
can't express to you what happened
inside of me when i heard i love love me
like a man on the regular version but
the live version specifically
like you know like on your thing it'll
be like what your favorites are what
you've listened to most and you're like
that is literally my favorite it's that
one and i never loved a man by aretha
franklin those are my two others
that's my favorite song of hers too
that's my favorite
if i could only have one song that would
be the one that's my favorite everything
that's why i like well i know that's why
we relay we're like sis telling you but
i i love that live version thank you so
much um it is literally just so amazing
and so soulful and so raw it's just so
good thank you
and honestly too i'm gonna say this is
no shade to anyone but it's also you're
from a time too like people had to be
able to be amazing live you know what
i'm saying like
you it wasn't a time when you could
digitally fix everything it wasn't it
and and that carries over and it's just
such a lesson like i was just talking to
my stylist like you performed i forgot
what show it was we were watching and
you got on stage and it was like well
and that's how you were supposed to do
it every once in a while like it was
like it literally is it's like you're
you just you sound amazing live and
that's not true for everyone not
throwing shade at anyone just saying
that's what it is and well i didn't sell
a lot of records the first 20 years and
then even with nick of time was like a
little blip of a couple of albums that
did well but i knew if i just did every
show really good that people would keep
coming to see me you know what that's so
true everybody's always worried about
winning awards and my thing is like i
don't really care about winning the
award i just want the performance slot
because i just want to prove exactly
what i can do that's totally with you
yes i mean give me a live show and i'll
approve one yeah that's what yeah
there's something that happens in us i
love it so thank you for appreciating
that live version because
it's
amazing
and that just doesn't exist i don't feel
anymore with artists so but wait are you
looking forward to getting back out
there because i know a lot of artists
are because everybody's been on hold
stuff like two and a half years yes we
had a lot last week was the first warm
up shows first audience i heard in two
and a half years it doesn't feel good oh
my god that was right you feed off of it
i mean it was the first time i'd sung
angel from montgomery since john passed
and oh wow i can't make you love me it
was like transcendent and i've got a
couple of new guys in the band and i
hadn't seen my guys until we got in the
studio last june to make my album that
was a long after 50 years on the road to
have that much time without playing in
front of people because i also think
people don't realize like your band is
like your second you see them sometimes
more than your actual family yeah so so
that's a really big hole of isolation
like especially for a creative person
well it's a good thing we have texting
incentives face time pictures
yeah anyway bonnie is performing later
in the show so stick around a new album
is called just like that and it's out
tomorrow you can also go online to find
tickets for her tour which is happening
right now you gotta go check her out
because not many artists sound like this
live people
[Music]
you